c'est répartir celui de veste oui c'est
possible oui cette saint-quentinoise
programme ses prochaines vacances
un voyage plus tôt en octobre mais
surtout s'en sortir de l'europe
on voyage pas mal surtout mon mari mais
je connais pas but alpes est est ce un
rêve d'y aller depuis très longtemps
c'est un projet qu'on a depuis depuis
deux ans et on aimerait bien bien le
faire dans cette agence à nîmes antennes
les demandes ont été réduites
emmanuel van un voyage par jour à la
même époque l'année dernière deux à
trois séjours étaient réservées
quotidiennement et pour l'été la
tendance va plutôt à l'hexagone
beaucoup nous disent ben je veux pas
partir en dehors de la france parce que
si jamais on doit être confiné
on veut pas être confinée à la
destination est d'autant plus d'avoir à
payer les frais que ça engendre être
resté bloqué dans un pays étranger
le vent me
ma vie pour l'instant on ne peut pas y
aller un voyage hors d'europe encore
compliquer dès le 1er juillet les
français peuvent se déplacer en dehors
de l'union européenne à condition que
l'épidémie soit maîtrisé dans le pays
souhaitait pour cette agence
versaillaise 150 voyages ont été annulés
depuis le confinement
même là des gens qui devaient partir le
3 juillet jean d'avoir une annulation de
vol pour la guadeloupe donc vraiment on
n'a aucune certitude
et c'est ça qui est le plus on va dire
le plus compliqué ce qu'on ne peut pas
les rassurer ils sont ça se comprend
qu'ils sont ils ont envie de partir mais
nous on n'a pas plus d'informations
selon les entreprises du voyage cette
année 87 % des français projette de
partir en vacances en france et 13% à
l'étranger lors des années précédentes
ils étaient plus de 30% à quitter
l'hexagone